(lively guitar music)
- I set the record for the lowest limbo
of 8.5 inches in 2010.
I'm very proud of that.
My name is Shemika Campbell,
and I am a world class limbo dancer.
(steel drum music)
I'm originally from Trinidad and Tobago,
which is also where
limbo dance originated.
It was a dance at wakes that symbolized
entering from one life to another.
Now today, it's literally everywhere.
I got into the art of
limbo at the age of 14.
My grandmother was a limbo dancer,
my mother was a limbo dancer
and it's only right
that I'm a limbo dancer.
I had to carry on that legacy,
not only for my family,
but also for my culture, as well.
(bright music)
Physically, I am very flexible.
I do my daily stretches.
I can't really feel normal stretches,
so I have to like create my own,
to where I really feel
the stretch in my legs.
I get a little crazy sometimes, for sure.
- Ladies and gentlemen, the
limbo queen, Shemika Campbell.
(cheering)
- [Shemika] In order to
make it under 8.5 inches,
I have to hold my breath in order
to contort my body to
make it under the bar.
At the same time I have to think
about my arms, I have to
think about my positioning.
I move side to side just to show
that I'm still suspended.
I start to move actually
physically under the bar
and that's pretty much when I'm able
to let the air out.
And that's when I will get up.
It's very very very hard to do.
The pain that I feel during practicing
and pushing myself that comes with it,
that's one of the things
that really drew me to limbo.
It was something that
I couldn't do easily.
I love the challenge.
Me making it under this
bar perfectly every time,
it means the absolute world.
(cheering)
I pretty much limbo any and everywhere.
I've been on “America's Got Talent” twice.
I've been on “The Ellen Degeneres show.”
I've been on “The Late Late
Show with James Corden.”
When I see peoples' reactions
and how appreciative they are
of my ability to do this is just amazing.
Alright.
Put it there, put it there.
- I really do appreciate
you representing the city.
- I absolutely love limbo.
I love everything about it.
People think that limbo is just for fun.
For Trinidadians like myself,
it's really a big part of our culture.
I feel like that's where my job comes in,
to really show you this is more
than just a fun little activity.
- [Man] Whoa.
(clapping and cheering)